anyone good evening
thank you for being here tonight for
this important covid19
update tonight i'm grateful that dr tony
sloanum
the president and chief executive
officer at renowned health could be here
with me to share the very real burden
that covet 19 is having on our
communities
you will hear from him shortly
as you are all aware our country and
states
are on a very rough course right now
when it comes to the coronavirus and its
trajectory
new cases hospitalizations
and tragically fatalities are on the
rise
the fall spike predicted by all medical
and scientific experts
is now our reality nevadans
need to accept and understand this
reality now
and change behaviors immediately
i'm encouraged by this week's news about
a potential covet 19
vaccine it gives me hope and it should
give you hope
our nevada team is closely monitoring
these updates
and adjusting our vaccine distribution
framework so we are ready
when the time comes but an accessible
vaccine isn't ready today
it won't be ready tomorrow and it won't
be ready next week
and based on our current case numbers we
can't wait
for a vaccine to get this deadly virus
back into a manageable level
we don't have much time to act to avoid
a dangerous hospital surge
and keep our economy going and keep
people at work
we are walking a tightrope between
maintaining faith services
commerce and recreational activity
and protecting lives our public safety
frontline workers
in our healthcare infrastructure
we all must act right now to keep our
economy open
and eventually begin to restore other
parts of our life
like schools family gatherings
and entertainment venues but
and this is very important in the next
two weeks
two weeks we must see a significant
reversal of the current trends
which are deeply concerning now there
were more than
thirteen hundred new cases identified
yesterday
more than eight thousand new tests and
unfortunately
seven additional deaths
our 14-day positivity rate is an
astounding
13.7 percent is continuing to climb
for the most recent seven day period
cases are growing at a rate of one point
two percent
or one thousand three hundred and twenty
six new cases per day
one thousand three hundred and twenty
six new cases
per day the nevada hospital
hospital association reports that nevada
continues
the upward trajectory of covet 19 cases
as the population appears to have
disengaged from mitigation steps
such as social distancing and remote
working
monday marked the highest recorded
number of hospitalizations
since mid-august effectively erasing the
progress made
over the past three months
to preserve our state's economy we must
refocus on preventing the spread of
covet 19.
we have to go back to the basics which
by now
are pretty common knowledge wearing
masks
maintaining social distancing of at
least six feet and limiting the risk of
exposure
and washing your hands are the only ways
we can keep going
in the right direction the only proven
way to control the current widespread
transmission of covet
is to decrease mobility that means
staying home
as much as we possibly can thus
we have stay at home 2.0
as a result for the next two weeks two
weeks nevadans need to operate in the
stay-at-home 2.0 mentality
to get things under control so our
public health
response infrastructure can catch up
we need that time to bring testing
timelines down
catch up on contact racing and relieve
our health care infrastructure system
we need swift action to change our
behaviors so we can see a downward
trajectory
at the end of this 14-day period
if you don't have to go out don't go up
reduce your time in public to what is
necessary
and limit any and all exposures to those
outside of your household
think about changes like ordering
groceries for delivery
instead of going into the store or
picking up dinner outside
curbside from your favorite restaurant
instead of sitting indoors
with others who are not members of your
family
avoid gatherings large and small
our businesses are doing what they can
to keep employees and customers safe
but we need those employees to practice
all public health measures as home
and as well as in the restaurants and
businesses
do not have people outside of your
household over for dinners
parties or other gatherings
connect over zoom or on the phone i know
this is an enormous sacrifice
for many people but what it's what needs
to be
done to stop the spread of this virus
we know from experience that temporarily
decreasing our activity in the community
can significantly reduce the spread of
covet 19
and reduce the burden on our health care
system
in march when we first implemented
stay-at-home orders much of nevada was
closed
including many of our key industries
this action was necessary and was taken
to avoid overwhelming our health care
facilities
and to reduce covet 19 related
fatalities
while the state home measures work to
flatten the curve they also led to a
detrimental economic and social impacts
that will take time to recover from
[Music]
back in the spring we did not have the
experience or the data to guide our
decisions
and instead had to rely on models and
projections
we know more now we believe that we can
safely reduce the spread of covid in our
communities
without requiring closing sectors of our
economy
but to do this we asking each and every
nevadan
to do your part in slowing the spread of
covet and protecting
our most vulnerable i know you've heard
me say all of this before
but i'm asking you on behalf of our
health care workers
our emts and everyone on the front lines
who is seeing this alarming trend in the
wrong direction
please please do your part
if we can take action now we can keep
our businesses open
and reduce the spread of covet save
lives
and keep our health care system from
being overwhelmed
as government officials we can only
adopt and enforce restrictions in
businesses and public spaces
what you do at home in your own backyard
or your neighborhood
is almost more important please don't
let your guard down
at home
so we've got some specifics for you for
all employers and office spaces
we're asking that you telework as much
as possible
if employees can do their jobs from home
have them do so for the next two weeks
if employees have to be in the workspace
they need to be masked
at all times and meetings should be done
virtually from individual offices
instead of in conference rooms or shared
spaces
for commercial and government employees
employers this is not the time to
encourage or even allow crowded meetings
in indoor events
like birthday parties or retirement
parties
masks must be worn by everyone in
meetings of two people or more
for the entire duration of the meeting
keep the number of people in meetings to
a bare minimum
and keep the meetings short
i will be directing all state employees
to adhere to these common sense
practices
and encourage all local governments to
follow
to the private sector follow our lead
and help protect your businesses and
employees
faith leaders and places of worship
please review and remind the faithful of
all safety protocols
we've witnessed in other parts of the
country significant spread from wedding
celebrations
celebrations of life and other church
gatherings
from synagogues to mosques to churches
and chapels please take all necessary
measures
so we can continue to worship sometimes
these are done
unknowingly people get out of a mass or
service
and they congregate in the courtyard and
they catch up and they talk
and they spend time with each other
we're asking for two weeks to
stop that practice to please leave the
service
and get in your car and go home local
government
and enforcement i know the majority of
our businesses are doing a great job
but for those that aren't you are
threatening
nevada's economy in this critical moment
i do not want every business to suffer
with closures
because a small few refuse to follow the
protocols
so for the next two weeks we implore
every business to follow the protocols
that have been put in place
that's why i am asking local governments
to step up enforcement measures
over the next two weeks to ensure all
businesses
are doing their part this includes
citations
fines and potential license suspensions
i'm asking the local governments to
coordinate their efforts between
themselves
to help each other coordinate
and educate and enforce
and i'm calling on our universities and
our colleges to do more
i'm asking you to step up communicate
with your students
communicate with your faculty and avoid
any gatherings on any campuses
and in their homes get the message out
to all of your students
we've got two major airports in nevada
and i've been in both of them in the
last
week the compliance
is beginning to fall short people are
taking their masks off when they get off
the plane
they're wearing them under their nose or
on their chin
so for everyone's sake understand while
you are in one of the airports
it is mandatory mandatory
that you were a mask at all times unless
you're eating and drinking and for that
moment you can have the mask off
but while you are in the airport it is a
mandatory
issue that you wear your mask and i'm
asking both airports
to step up enforcement of mask wearing
for the next two weeks we must mimic our
stay-at-home behaviors from this past
spring
if we do so we believe we can begin to
turn around things in two weeks
without having to place increased
restrictions on our businesses
or our schools we do not want to do that
i do not want to do that we have a
chance to avoid that from happening
if we all help and we all pitch in
if we don't turn things around cases
will continue to grow out of
out of control hospitalizations will
continue to increase
and ultimately overwhelm our hospitals
hospitalizations will increase and
overwhelm our hospitals
medical staff and first responders will
continue they have
increased risk of exposure resulting in
staff shortages
across our state we cannot
afford that nightmare scenario but we
have two weeks to do it
and it will take every one of us to do
their part
again if we don't come together at this
moment
i will be forced to take stronger action
of 14 days
to be clear i don't want to take
stronger action
i do not want to implement more
restrictions i want this to improve
and we can make it improve if everyone
helps
i want to stay on the path to get all
nevada children back in classrooms
opening conventions by fifty percent by
january first
and lifting more restrictions that's the
path i've laid out for nevada
we need to decide if we want to remain
on it
i want all of our kids to go back to
school but i want them to go back safely
our students are suffering from mental
health issues i spoke to the clark
county
superintendent this afternoon and we
lost another student to suicide this
week that's not acceptable
and it's something that we can all do
our part to prevent from happening
some people are going to ask why not
limit retail our casino resorts
our restaurants right now
that's a fair question that's a
tightrope i was referring to
that is the tightrope of trying to
balance controlling
the covid spread protecting our
hospitals from surges
and at the same time not destroying and
shutting down our economy
i want to make every effort i want us
to make every effort to keep people on
their jobs
and to keep our economy moving forward
additionally
those businesses under scrutiny from
osha local authorities gaming
regulators and others will see an
increased enforcement
in those businesses and an increase
in violations and fines of people are
not complying
they are monitored for non-compliance
with mitigation protocols
and they will be fined for
non-compliance when standards are not
met additionally i have been asking the
various businesses and their
associations
to step up their in-house and back of
house communications
with their employees asking them to
follow our protocols
in the workplace and in the community
and when they go home if you this is
common sense if you're in a car pool
with four people that don't live in your
household
wear a mask when you're in the car i
mean
wear a mask at all times when is
at all possible additionally
there may be a perception of a double
standard here
but managing through this pandemic
protecting your health
and your jobs is a daily challenge
and the only way we can get to the other
side of this for all of us
is to fight this horrible virus together
while we might be getting coveted
fatigue
the virus is not getting infection
fatigue
we need to do more
properly wear your masks in any public
setting indoors and outside
okay and i'm going to make this real
simple properly wearing your mask
means covering your mouth and your nose
wearing it on your
ear or your chin or under your nose
is not properly wearing your mask
properly wearing your mask means your
nose
and your mouth are completely covered
avoid hosting meetings parties or
crowded events in small
indoor places maintain distance of at
least six feet
and limit close contact with people even
if you're wearing a mask
watch your head wash your hands often
and please stay home if you have any
flu-like symptoms
if you're not feeling well if you have
aches if you have a temperature
stay home activate the covet 19 trace
app on your phone
it makes tracing exposures much more
practical
much more convenient and much more rapid
than having to do it by hand
please sign up and activate the kova
trace app
at this time i'd like to turn it over to
dr tony sloanum to give nevadan some
in-depth insight
into what he is seeing throughout the
renowned health network
and what that means for nevadans if we
don't take steps to change
this trajectory dr stone
thank you governor sislek and thanks to
the many
many first responders physicians and
health care workers
of all disciplines throughout the state
who are doing their part
to address the needs of nevadans
as an icu physician a public health
professional
and a ceo of a health system that cares
for
hundreds of thousands of people i want
to ask all nevadans
to stay at home for the next 14 days and
please
follow the cdc guidelines to reduce the
spread of this
virus you see apart from my professional
roles
i also happen to be the son of a great
man who died from covert
back in april and it was a devastating
event and i think we can do more
as we try to stomp out this terrible
disease
but we need your help for the first time
in the last nine
months people are being hospitalized and
dying at higher
rates than ever before i am very
very concerned this is new
for those that know me they know i've
not had the same level of concern
previously
which is why i'm speaking out now and
why with our sister hospitals in
northern nevada
our city our county and our state
we need to better coordinate our efforts
to assure
an adequate public health response
we're unable to keep pace with the virus
in the way it's currently presenting
itself in our community
you can help us our first responders
doctors nurses and health care workers
are doing an amazing job every single
day
but we're working around the clock to
provide care that is becoming
increasingly difficult this past weekend
in order to meet the urgent needs of our
community we rush to open new units
and change our staffing models this week
we're planning to open our
alternate care site in our parking
garage
to accommodate an additional 1600 beds
right now we're benefited by the fact
that we've got ample ppe
supplies and equipment but the more
people who get sick
the more we will need to address their
needs
as a member of our community i'm asking
you to please please do the right thing
stay home wear a mask wash your hands
when you stay home you protect our
healthcare heroes on the front line
you protect yourself and your family and
you save a hospital bed
for someone who may really really need
it
thank you back to you governor thank you
with that i'd be uh happy to or dr
solomon i happy to take some questions
hi governor how are you good thanks for
doing this
so on october 20th you said the
trajectory was alarming but the future
depended
on residents on the 29th you said we're
not rounding the corner
and if we don't change course trade-offs
will be necessary it's november 10th and
the message feels similar
you don't believe we need closures to
curb the spread of the virus and are
imploring people to change behaviors
without state level action
why do you think this time imploring
residents is going to work differently
than it appears to have worked the last
two times
i don't want and you're right we i've
been delivering the same message here
for
weeks months understand i do not want to
close businesses
or implement more restrictions and i
don't think we need to if everyone
cooperates
but unfortunately there are some folks
that choose to
make light of this on social media
there's some folks that are
bloggers or columnists that make light
of the idea
and i'm asking them take a break for two
weeks let it go
i mean i'll be here to criticize two
weeks from now but i'm asking him for
two weeks to please
let it go and try to encourage people to
wear a mask
and just give it a chance and see if it
works i have confidence
in the citizens the residents of the
state of nevada
i have confidence in our elected
officials and i have confidence in our
businesses
i don't want them all to suffer so we're
giving it one last try
to see if we can get this under control
in two weeks
starting right now so today
at the economic forum the nevada resort
association
mentioned that kind of threshold that
you
dangled a few weeks ago about returning
to 50 convention capacity
by january for people confused about the
trends that you're outlining
and underlining the underlying ideas
behind that goal
what is your team's best case scenario
look like over the next two months and
is it realistic it's very realistic
i think there's a lot of good things in
our future there are possibilities
coming along
if we can get a handle on this virus
this time and the spread of this
the spread the infections the
hospitalizations and ultimately the
deaths
i think we can start a trajectory back
coming downward
i don't want to lose those conventions
aren't just people coming here
they're people that are spending money
here there's jobs that are being created
here
and we can get our economy back to
moving again but that's not my call
that's each and every one of your call
to make if you're willing to cooperate
and pitch in and help us out here i'm
not asking for the world
14 days is what i'm asking for
please and i know people criticize
wearing masks and they protest and go
back and forth give it a break
give it a rest for 14 days to see if we
can try to get a handle on this because
i believe the citizens
residents nevada can do that
hi governor um i wanted to ask 14 days
from now is going to put us
at the tuesday before thanksgiving what
kind of restrictions
are you considering to put in place
before then are you ready to kind of put
those uh
additional tightening of restrictions in
place so close to that holiday
i'm willing to put the restrictions in
place only if we're forced to do that
i mean i'm not bluffing i'm not playing
a game
this isn't just because i want to see
all you hear tonight that we're having a
press conference
we are in a very crucial point right now
i've got doctors who i have an enormous
amount of respect for
telling me and scientists telling me
that we are on the verge of being
overwhelmed
i don't know what we will uh have to
decide
in 14 days i'm hopeful that in 14 days
i'll be standing for you saying the
people in nevada came through again
they did what i knew they could do they
pull together
and we're on the right track i don't
want to think what's going to happen in
14 days if we don't
because what we're facing is a very
difficult situation
riley dr sloanum he lost his father
to coven i talk to people on a regular
basis
that lose a family member that lose a
loved one
that themselves are infected and
sometimes it's not until you are
affected that they get the
the realization of how serious this is
but you know one person takes it home
and suddenly the husband and you know
four kids got it
you know one gives the grandson gives it
to the mother gives it to the sister
gives it the father the grandparent
it spreads so quickly we need to do more
and i am confident that if we really
buckle down hard for two weeks
two weeks we can make an in-run
i have not read the plan i know it's 200
plus pages and i you know
i'll try to get to reading the plan i
have talked to dr jarrah
i am very concerned about getting our
kids back in the classroom
i understand we need to make sure that
it's done in a safe manner
but as i told you i think he told me as
a nine-year-old that we lost this week
that committed suicide it's too much
it's gone too far
we need to give kids a chance we need to
have that outlet in school
i'm confident that they can do it safely
and that's not my area that's our
superintendent our state superintendent
joan ebert has done an incredible job
working with the school districts
one we still don't have any in class
time is clark and
we're working to make that happen if the
current
statistics and trajectory of covet
continues the way it does do you think
that
clark county school district other
school districts should step away from
in-person learning well
riley if it continues to increase as
it's going now
i don't know what restrictions we're
going to have to put in place but
they're going to be
severe they're going to be hard and
they're going to be things that
people aren't going to want to do and
and i get that but but
we don't have to do any of that i don't
want to focus on what we're going to do
if this doesn't work because i want to
believe i do believe this will work
if we get everybody to efficient
hi governor i'm going to belabor the
point we're nine months into this uh
this pandemic and we're still having
debates in the public about wearing
masks
why isn't it wishful thinking to think
that you know every import tuning
is going to change this time is what
hasn't worked over the months we've been
going through this bill that's a great
question i've been asking for a long
long time to wear a mask
i get people protesting in front of the
capitol they protest in front of my
house both in the north and in the south
that i'm taking away their liberties i i
do not know
why people this is not we're not
campaign season anymore here
this is not a political statement this
mask
is warned to protect me and my loved
ones
and to protect others that i am near
that's what this mask is for
i mean we're not asking somebody to you
know do something that is extremely
onerous
and i know people are going to criticize
me for saying please wear a mask
they're going to have their social media
platforms up there give it a break
could you please just give it a break
for two weeks
and see if we can all work together and
if we're all working together
you're going to be surprised how much
good that we can do we've got frontline
hospital workers here doctors nurses
emts
they're putting their lives on the line
every day for us and
it's too much to wear a mask you get
criticized for asking people to wear a
mask
that's not acceptable for me so i'm
telling you we've got two weeks
that's it i'm not going to come back in
two weeks and say i'm going to give you
another chance because i'm not giving
you another chance
my question was more to the point of why
aren't you taking stronger action now
why don't you order
people to wear masks well the reason
we're taking such strong action now as i
see the number of cases the
hospitalization infection rate going up
at such an alarming rate
i see that when we've got we're bumping
up to 900 i think on hospitalizations
and we've got
you know we're averaging 1300 positives
a day
1300 that's four times what it was
what six weeks ago i mean we can't keep
going if it goes up four times more
we're in a big we're in a world of hurt
so
the alarm right now is because the
infections have gone up
the hospitalizations have gone up the
fatalities will follow
and go up that's just inevitable and i
want everyone to understand
just how important this is that you wear
a mask at all times
someone comes to visit your house and
they don't have a mask on tell them what
went on
tell them that you know put one on to
protect themselves and to protect you
i mean that's what we have to start
doing and you need to be thinking of
other people don't just think of
yourself
think of your family think of these
front line workers think of a doctor who
lost his father
because people won't follow protocols
and if we don't approve this it's going
to be on those folks that don't
cooperate
for the reason this infection rate
continues to climb because i'm telling
you
the vast majority of nevadans are doing
a good job
it's the outliers that aren't doing a
good job and they're the ones that are
going to own this
they're going to have to live with the
fatalities and the affections that we
have
i talk to people that are dealing that
are hospitalized
it's not easy so please help us
i'm going to steal one more question the
federal government as
withholding distribution of rapid covet
tests from several states
including nevada saying that we haven't
used the tests that we have
do you have a comment on that is that
yeah it's my understanding uh
from my briefing on that that what we
had is a problem of the distribution
that the federal government put in some
criteria for the licensure those people
that distribute those tests
and we can't distribute them without
those folks having that licensure and
they don't have it
so we're working to get more licensed
folks available to distribute those debt
okay thank you you bet
so these are restrictions to two people
in meetings those
are part of directive correct not
recommendations is that correct
these are this is not a directive okay
this is a
persian personal impassioned plea
for people to please step up and do
these things now a lot of these are in
place already
you know businesses have to have
protocols in place they have to have
mass
they have to have social distancing our
universities and colleges need to do
more i'm asking our airports you can't
you have to wear masking airport now
it's just not being enforced as much and
we need to do better
we need to do better um
14 days from now you don't see a change
what kind of restrictions are you
looking at
in regards to business are you talking
are you looking at full shutdowns
or is it something that you're more
looking at further restrictions i i
don't want to speculate what we'll do in
14 days
it's going to depend on what our rate is
at that time
as compared to now if we've made any
impact at all if it's starting to come
down or not
and it's going to have to be
severe in order for us to get a handle
on this now it's just a question of how
much we're going to have to get a handle
on
what position we're going to be in in 14
days you saw when we
had the shutdowns the cases came down
i don't want to do that again i don't do
that again
anybody's got any questions for dr sloan
i'm here
hi governor so today you're asking local
governments to step
up and coordinate efforts i'm wondering
a few months in does
this devolved decision-making strategy
leaving it to counties to submit
mitigation plans to a state task force
rather than using more statewide
measures do you think it's the optimal
strategy still
i do think it's the optimal strategy we
do not have enough resources at the
state level we have osha
business and industry that's going out
and they're doing a lot of enforcement
and some of it's a little higher profile
you see it because the fines are a lot
larger
but we can't go into every uh county and
every city in every township
and walk into grocery stores and
restaurants and whatnot they they have
these folks who are allocated resources
through the
uh karezak money to enforce the
the protocols and the directives and i'm
calling upon them right now to start
14 days starts now it starts right now
so i'm asking them to get out in the
communities
and to do something i saw a comment
before i walked up here from mayor
sheevy in reno that said that she's
going to
start enforcing the mass mandate she's
going to start
visiting more businesses i'm asking
every single jurisdiction
to do that everyone is there any
evidence that the osha finds you just
mentioned
is there any evidence that they're
working to any sort of
mitigation and well i think they're
working for the people that are getting
fined you know and then i think what
happens is other people see that if you
break the rules if you have too big of
gathering if you don't have people doing
social distancing if they're in a big
group or they're not wearing their masks
i better get my act together or i'm
going to get fine
so we still think it's a deterrent
department we still think it's a
deterrent
i do believe it's going to deter i
absolutely do but we need to do more to
make it even more of a deterrent
thank you
so governor i'm hoping you can clarify
um you're using the phrase stay at home
2.0 you're asking people to stay at home
as much as possible
do you want people from out of state to
stop coming to nevada is there a line
there that you want to draw in terms of
out-of-state tourism or people coming
over from california to visit vegas for
a weekend should they not come over
these next 14 days no
they certainly should come because those
are protecting our jobs but when they
come here and they're staying in one of
our properties
they need to wear a mask when they're in
one of our restaurants
the restaurant has protocols in place
that they have to follow
and that both the employers employees
and the guests have to follow
i'm asking if they're going into a have
a drink if they're going to you know
play
cards or you know a slot machine
whatever it might be
wear a mask that's what i'm asking for
i'm not implementing any new
restrictions right now
i'm encouraging them to come but i'm
encouraging to please
please follow the rules and if everybody
would just
pitch in and i mean this from the bottom
of my heart i mean
i know people are going to complain that
i'm asking for more
cooperation i know people are going to
complain about
asking for more enforcement i know some
of the social media people are going to
find a way to criticize what we're
saying
can you please just give it a chance for
two weeks can we please
try to get this under control for two
weeks i'm not saying you got to do this
until
march you know which is an unreasonable
amount of time to most people
i'm saying for 14 days can everybody
please pitch in and see how much good we
can do
and i think it's going to have an
enormous impact great thank you governor
thank you
anybody have any questions for dr
sloanum on the medical
scenario in side um this might be a
possible association question for that
for now
how close are we to the worst-case
scenario i.e
no visitors beds in hallways
is that something that is on the horizon
for now
yeah at the moment it's not and we hope
that we've learned a whole bunch of
things across the last six to eight
months
that allow us to address some of those
issues
but i don't take opening a parking
garage and putting hospitalized patients
in it lightly
and that's where we are likely this week
which is why
it's one of the things one of the
reasons why i'm speaking out now we need
the help of the community
if we're going to be able to stave off
anything worsening
from this pandemic we're putting our
healthcare workers at risk we're putting
each other at risk
we've got to do better doctor
did i understand you that are we now
using that
the emergency award that you built over
in the parking lot
we're not using it yet i expect but
you're on that you're on the edge of
using it
we're on the edge of using it
thank you thanks everybody
[Applause]